he owes the Elder Scrolls online game
director Matt fire Matt thanks everyone
good evening this week is the one-year
anniversary of the launch of the Elder
Scrolls online on xbox one and
playstation 4 because we were launching
the game this time last year I was a
little busy and I wasn't able to be here
in person but I made sure I was here
this year to tell everyone what's been
happening with the Elder Scrolls online
from the console launch last June to the
release of three critically acclaimed
DLC game packs during the year all of us
in Santa max online have been really
really busy but before I go any further
I want to take a moment and thank all of
our fans for your support Your
Enthusiasm and your feedback we take it
really seriously and we continue to work
to improve the game and based on the
response you like the changes elder
scrolls online was named mmog em that
best mmog of 2015 was one of the
best-selling games of the year of any
kind and now supports a highly engaged
community of over 7 million of you who
have been exploring this enormous world
of Tamriel let's take a look at some of
the highlights from the older Scrolls
online from launch onward
as you can see the auto Scrolls online
community is having a lot of fun playing
the game and our player community is
still growing tonight I'm very happy to
announce that on june twenty third will
be expanding internationally by
launching Elder Scrolls online in Japan
we look forward to welcoming these
fellow adventurers to the exciting world
of Tamriel and for everyone who plays we
have a lot more great content on the way
for me one of my favorite moments in any
RPG ever was a dark brotherhood quest in
the older squirrels for Oblivion it was
packed for of assassination and intrigue
and like me fans everywhere loved it so
I'm particularly excited for the launch
of the Dark Brotherhood DLC game pack on
xbox one and playstation 4 this Tuesday
in the dark brotherhood DLC you'll
travel to another location from oblivion
the gold coast of Cyrodiil the Dark
Brotherhood has a appropriately dark
story line full of intrigue and mystery
and brings all new repeatable quests
game played at ESO so please enjoy the
worldwide debut of the Dark Brotherhood
DLC launch trailer
sweet mother sweet mother send your
child unto me for the sins of the
unworthy must be baptized in blood and
fear this is the black sacrament
initiate a contract for crews for murder
now go assassin take your blade into the
night be rewarded for your service
in our business
of death
welcome in the [ __ ] to the dark
brotherhood and know this in 10 Ryo no
one is safe
especially from us
father sweet mother your child unto me
our PC players are already having fun
sneaking around Tamriel and learning
more about them it's this mysterious
group and we can't wait to see what
happens when our console players get to
experience the Dark Brotherhood this
week but that's not all a core
philosophy and the older scrolls online
is to constantly make the game better
since launch we've regularly been adding
innovative features such as the justice
system in the champion system and we're
about to make another game changer
tonight we're announcing one Tamriel
marking another major evolution of
gameplay in the Elder Scrolls online
with one Tamriel all characters will be
automatically leveled to content in the
world allowing them to freely group with
anyone they want and also to explore the
vast world of Tamriel with no level
restrictions this means this means all
content barriers are gone and there are
no restrictions on alliances requesting
from the moment you get out of the
tutorial the entire game world is open
for you to explore freely you can go
wherever you want and play with whomever
you want this is the first time this has
ever been done in a multi-platform RPG
will think you'll love it
one tamriel will be coming to the Elder
Scrolls online this fall in closing I
want to thank the awesome elder scrolls
online community for your support we
never take it for granted we work hard
every day to make your over Scrolls
online experience the awesome adventure
you want and deserve thanks everyone